[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat souriez vous êtes
filmés
depuis ces dernières années les caméras
de surveillance ont fleuri un peu
partout en france y compris dans les
yvelines
destiné à assurer la protection des
habitants leur usage a été étendu à la
vidéo verbalisation pour les infractions
routières plébiscitée par de plus en
plus de mères ces outils porterait
atteinte aux libertés individuelles
selon leurs opposants la vidéoprotection
est elle utile mais aussi efficace c'est
le débat du jour et pour en parler
autour de cette table jacques jean luc
hugo bonsoir mon choix vous êtes maire
de montigny le bretonneux en face de
vous philippe benassaya bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes maire de bois d'arcy vous êtes
également vice-président de versailles
grand parc en charge de la
vidéoprotection également un pierre
déjean grand soir est le porte parole de
la ligue des droits de l'homme dans les
yvelines merci à tous les trois d'être
présent ce soir alors pour commencer
juste un rapide état des lieux dans
chacune de vos communes messieurs jean
luc ourgaud depuis quand
la ville de montigny a mis en place des
vidéosurveillances ça fait maintenant 12
ans 12 ans que la vidéo surveillance la
vidéo-verbalisation pardon est en place
alors dans deux emplacements très
délimiter la place claudel et marc
caillaud centre commercial de la marque
hayon c'est sur les deux seuls endroits
de la ville qui sont vidéo sur combien
de caméras sur le nombre total de
caméras on a aujourd'hui 77 caméra très
précise et après des raisons qui vous
ont poussé à mettre en place ce système
de surveillance eux mêmes questions
philippe benassaya depuis quand la vidéo
protection a été mise en place à bois
d'arcy
depuis que le schéma directeur de
versailles grand parc a été adoptée en
2010 c'est à dire que la vidéo
protection est une compétence delà de la
communauté d'agglomération versailles
grand parc avant 2014 il y avait deux
caméras je crois deux ou trois caméras
bonheur si aujourd'hui il y en a 15 et
sur l'ensemble de versailles grand parc
aujourd'hui il y en a 400 voilà donc moi
je gère plutôt les 400 caméras du
territoire de versailles en pas les 19
communes et d'ici 2020 il devrait y en
avoir 25 e sahaba darthial caméra
souvient alors qu'est ce qui vous a
conduit finalement à à mettre en place
ces caméras
alors pour plusieurs raisons d'abord le
désengagement de l'état qui nous offre
qui nous pousse à nous organiser nous
dans les communes c'est à dire que il
nous autorise l'état nous autorise à
créer des centres de supervision urbain
c'est à dire des centres qui permet de
surveiller toutes les villes avec des
agents de devil qui regardent les écrans
et qui permet de voir ce qui se passe en
direct deuxièmement ça nous permet
d'aider la justice puisque les images
sont réquisitionnés comme on dit soit
par la police soit par le procureur
ces images sont stockées dix jours et
ensuite après dix jours on les écrase
comme on dit voilà
troisièmement les images sont floutés
dès lors que les
les parties privées sont sont filmés et
quatrièmement ça permet également un
effet dissuasif
lorsqu un quartier où un square une grue
est surveillé il y as et les
statistiques sont là je les vois à peu
près tous les jours sur mon bureau
les statistiques de la délinquance sont
en baisse dès lors que les quartiers
sont reliés à un système de
vidéoprotection lutter contre les délits
jean-luc ourgaud c'est aussi la raison
qui vous a convaincu pour installer ses
caméras écoutez c'est un montini ça
remonte à notre ancien maire nicolas
bour c'est lui qui a installé les
premières caméras sur montigny et
c'était dès cette époque principalement
pour reprendre les propos de mon
collègue pour surveiller certaines zones
dans dans un quartier en particulier
donc c'est ce qui nous a je dirai
ensuite amené à développer que ce soit
mon prédécesseur michel laugier ou
moi-même ou puisqu'aujourd'hui on
continue implanter des caméras c'est ce
maillage de réseau de caméras qui nous
permet justement d'avoir une efficacité
au quotidien et et comme l'a dit aussi
mon collègue pour pallier au
désengagement de l'état puisque
maintenant sonder ce sont nos agents de
la police municipale au centre de
surveillance ou csu comme on dit qui
regarde les images et qui permettent aux
patrouilles d'intervenir beaucoup plus
rapidement quand il ya des difficultés
rencontrées pierre déjean la ligue des
droits de l'homme estime en fait que ses
caméras porte atteinte aux libertés
individuelles pourquoi tout simplement
déjà parce que il s'agit bien de
surveillance et surtout de surveillance
généralisée alors qu'on veuille de
surveiller des personnes qui commettent
des délits les empêcher de l'un à titre
individuel mais là il s'agit d' seriez
tout le monde tous ceux qui partent dans
la rue sont surveillés et on présente
toujours évidemment le cet aspect sousse
bonjour en disant que ça fait des c la
délinquance
ce qui reste à prouver en tout cas au
point de vue générale sur toutes les
caméras qui peuvent être installés en
france et je dirais même dans le monde
quelquefois d'ailleurs certains parlent
d' effet plumeau c'est à dire qu'en fait
la délinquance ne serait pas supprimée
encore si le petite délinquance des
incivilités part de la grande
délinquance mais envoyer ailleurs
mais cette efficacité n'a jamais été
globalement démontré par contre
effectivement on commence par un petit
bout dire qu'on dit tiens on va
surveiller pour la petite délinquance
pour les sensibilités puissent eux c'est
qui ça et d'année en année on ne
s'aperçoit que les lois changent que les
motifs de surveillants se demandent que
le nom de personnes surveillées augmente
et puis on a réussi tivement à la
surveillance généralisée c'est pourtant
très encadrée justement comment ça se
passe pour mettre en place ces caméras
il faut une autorisation du préfet
notamment c'est c'est très très très
encadrée heureusement d'ailleurs c'est
très encadré il y as schéma directeur
pour notre part à versailles grand parc
qu'un schéma directeur qui gère c'est à
dire que la vidéo protection comme la
vidéo verbalisation à l'avenir est
encadré par plusieurs critères on ne
peut pas d'abord vous ferez y pas les
gens ont déjà cessé la premier critère
de la vidéoprotection on n'est pas là à
regarder ce que font les gens on est là
on stocke des images qui permet à la
justice et à la police de pouvoir les
ressortir pour élucider des affaires
donc ça c'est la première la première
des choses
la deuxième des choses qui est bien
évidemment surveiller pas les gens dans
le domaine privé c'est interdit et la
troisième chose c'est que pour la vidéo
verbalisation par exemple ça ne peut
être qu'un policier municipal qui
verbalisent devant l'écran à distance
les infractions ça ne peut pas être un
asvp comme on dit c'est à dire un agent
de de la voie publique est un agent de
la ville c'est s'éteint c'est un
policier municipal je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est très très encadrée s'est
demandé par la police s'est demandée par
la justice est demandée par l'état
si l'état faisait son travail je pense
qu'on ferait l'économie de la
vidéoprotection dans les communes
je veux dire par là c'est que depuis
averses un grand parc par exemple nous
avons investi 12 millions d'euros en
caméra ce qui est beaucoup
je pense que ces 12 millions d'euros
aurait pu être bon et puis servir à
autre chose
donc c'est une évolution c'est une
évolution qui qui touche toutes les
villes d'ailleurs quelle que soit la
couleur politique de ces villas à
différentes allures il ya des vies
depuis historique de devil un peu moins
historique moi la mienne par exemple
était plutôt réfractaires en 2014 à la
vidéoprotection dès lors que le schéma
directeur l'imposent nous avons bien sûr
étendu la vidéoprotection dans la ville
donc c'est très encadré c'est pas on
serait pas on s'amuse pas l'encouragent
à venir d'ailleurs dans un cs eu la nuit
et vous verrez le travail des des agents
qui regarde ce qui se passe au niveau
des incivilités dans les lieux parce
qu'il ya des sensibilités et de la
délinquance petites et grandes dents
dans nos villes parfois bien des gens
une réaction je veut bien accorder
crédit de la bonne foi aux deux maires
qui sont là je ne les accuse de rien je
n'accuse pas en tout cas eu de
surveillance généralisée par contre le
système qui est mis en place permet
cette surveillance généralisée et elle
permet cette surenchère
oui venez venez voir les signatures
c'est ça qu'il faut il faut il faut
venez voir c'est un peu je dis que ça le
permet pourquoi pas parce que déjà
toutes ces caméras 1
elles sont reliées à un même réseau à
partir du moment où c'est dans un réseau
je vais dire des esprits malveillants
pour ne choquer personne peuvent s'y
introduire et détourner les images ou
les capter et oui mais oui c'est une
étable
c'est déjà ça pas vu pas pris non pas
pour nous pour tous il attendait juste
revenir sur le point puis semble être
votre argumentaire de la surveillance
des personnes
puis quand vous prenez le train quand
vous servez sortir de l'argent à un
distributeur
quand vous rentrez dans un bus man 10
ans vous êtes vous êtes filmés
on est on est filmé de parthenay part ça
veut pas dire pour autant que la sncf on
ouvre la ratp exploite les images
individuelles celles ci ne sont
exploités que lorsqu'il ya une
sensibilité je prendre ce terme
colvin constater hélas à ce moment là
les images sont examinées mais pour
l'individu qui a été enterré par la
police les autres personnes qui
circulent on n'exploite pas désigné
je rappelle excusé mondiale et rappelé
en quelques secondes privons pas
exploiter le même les images les images
doit être réquisitionnés par la justice
par le procureur par la police oui parle
la ddsp ce qu'on appelle la direction
départementale de la sécurité puis je
n'ai pas moi
possibilité de récupérer des méduses
j'en ai pas le droit que j'en suis mêmes
sont valorisés par effraction comme vous
le dites j'encours d'énormes risques que
je mènerai jamais de ma vie j'en suis
convaincu et j'ai bien dit tout à
l'heure que je ne mettais pas en croire
mes yeux ces accords se détendent et
pour prendre un exemple il a eu il ya
quelques années une histoire à propos
des ce qu'on appelle les je crois c'est
que les fadettes où tout comme ça les
relevés téléphoniques qui normalement
effectivement ne sont pas des cibles et
que la police a été les chercher
contre toutes les lois qui existaient et
ils ont obtenu ces complications donc
rien ne dit qu effectivement la police
celle d'aujourd'hui ou celle de demain
je parle pas de la police en tant
qu'individu mais de ceux qui les
commandent rien ne dit qu'ils vont pas
aller effectivement
mais quand vous me dites que
effectivement on est un frein
quand on me dit qu'effectivement on est
vidéosurveillées parce qu'il sait bien
de surveillance quand on va à la banque
chercher des sous quand on va prendre le
train a conçu cela mais je suis d'accord
sauf que ça a grincé agréable quand
parce que ça veut dire qu'il existe des
milliers de réseaux qui sont plus ou
moins interconnectés dans la mesure où
ils finissent simple ils s'appuient tous
sur le même réseau téléphonique et que
ça permet une vidéo surveillance de
masse totale et je vous rappelle que on
a parlé tout à l'heure avant de rentrer
il ya le département qui attend
d'installer enfin je pressais ce fait
mais c'est un projet des milliers de
caméras dans le département et si vous
en référé à ce qui était annoncé il y a
où il y aura derrière ce système un
certain de calculateurs ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence artificielle ce qui est
d'ailleurs un oxymore il n'y a pas du
tout d'intelligence mais c'est important
ça veut dire que on va repérer les gens
et le le président du conseil général
10e détecter les gestes suspect mais
c'est quoi un geste suspect est-ce que
c'est dans une manifestation quelqu'un
qui lève le poing ris je fais le régime
en place
on peut philosopher je suis déjà battue
désolait il s'agit d'actes de monsieur
visagie date si vous permettez dans de
rajouter quelques quelques secondes dans
ces cas-là internet est touchée parce
que dans sur sur internet nous sommes là
également entre guillemets flics et les
parkings souterrains on prend nos
plaques dire soit on abroge l'évolution
du numérique dans ce pays et on revient
à la situation ante et pourquoi pas
aujourd'hui une évolution qui est normal
ce système de vidéoprotection est
extrêmement bien encadrer les images ne
sont pas disponibles pour le public ni
d'ailleurs pour les élus ces images sont
disponibles dès lors qu'il y ait une
réquisition par le procureur de la
république ce qui est quand même
une marque importante la population
n'est pas surveillée personne n'est
surveiller c'est pas les films
d'espionnage
c'est simplement des images qui sont qui
songe pas est-ce que c'est fréquent
justement là par exemple le début de
l'année est ce que c'est un écran
proville il y a eu l'année dernière
cette réquisition sur l'année et cette
année depuis le mois de mai il y a eu je
crois de réquisition c'est qui ne donne
rien c'est à dire que très souvent la
police comme la justice regard des
images en mon absence d sûrement je ne
regarde rien encore une fois et il
ça sert à lenquête où ça ne sert pas l'
enquête l'année dernière ça servira le
démantèlement d'une bande à bois d'arcy
qui écumait les maisons et les pavillons
madar 6 grâce à la vidéoprotection cette
bande a été repéré par les caméras et
ont été suivis jusqu'à j'ai pas quelle
ville où ils ont été ils ont été arrêtés
moi je trouve que c'est plutôt positif
pour nos villes est positif pour les
citoyens écoutez moi quand quand je vois
les les demandes qui me sont faites en
réunion publique les les habitants sont
demandeurs de soins est alors à montigny
sur l'année dernière on a eu 76 très
précisément réquisition de la police et
quand je vois ce drame qui s'est passé
il ya à peu près un mois à la gare de
saint quentin une jeune fille a été
violée
à 1h ou 2h du matin et que grâce à la
caméra de la banque où elle était en
train de faire du distributeur de
billets où elle était en train de
retirer de l'argent plus la caméra de la
ville et bien l'agresseur a été arrêté
dans les trois jours qui suivaient donc
moi je suis désolé il faut vivre avec
son temps
il faut pas il faut pas fliquer pardon
de se taire mais les personnes et c'est
pas du tout l'objet mon collègue maire
de bois d'arcy de la clairement précisée
mais il faut aujourd'hui vivre avec les
moyens que nous avons pour contrôler de
plus en plus les incivilités et
malheureusement de temps en temps les
agressions justement vous parlez des
habitants je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'en pensent les yvelines parce qu'on
l'a on leur a posé la question savoir ce
qu'il pensait justement de la
vidéoprotection et de la vidéo
verbalisation
c'est rassurant et puis comme je dis
qu'on n'a rien à se reprocher voila
voila on voit pas en quoi ce sera un
problème de ski et vidéo à notre insu
quand j'entends ça nous protège
quand les gens voient
des vols les agressions je pense que
cela va augmenter la sécurité et ça
remplace pas les êtres humains on sent
qu'on est surveillé mais en même temps
s'il ya des actes négatifs au violent ou
quelque chose comme ça c'est bien quand
même savoir trouve que c'est déshumanisé
1 c'est avec un agent on peut discuter
mais avec toutes ses vidéos ses
appareils on peut pas discuter et on est
pris en photo et puis point final sans
avoir vu le reportage auparavant donc la
grande majorité des réponses
les gens sont pour ça rassure et puis il
ya une dame khady oui c'est plus humain
discuter avec un pélissier sas a rejoint
aussi le propos de mon collègue avait si
l'état ne s'était pas d'engager
désengagé depuis des années ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui
on en serait nouville certainement pas
amené à installer des caméras une caméra
sur un mât
c'est à peu près 15 millions multiplié
par le nombre de caméras alors on en
pose pas de souci il ya des aides si
cool ou si vous voulez en dehors des
aides c'est à peu près en moyenne quinze
mille euros
croyez moi qu'on a bien d'autres choses
à financer dans nos communes
là aussi à cause du désengagement de
l'état en prêt en principal que de
mettre de l'argent dans des caméras sur
le ce que vient de dire monsieur au bo
sur le désengagement de l'état
effectivement avec l'argent pour être
utilisées à autre chose oui bien entendu
là nous sommes entièrement d'accord ça
pas de problème sur les micros caméras
je suis pas surpris d'abord parce que
il ya les deux opinions puis de toute
façon c'est très bien moi je n'ai rien
contre les gens qu intervienne mais
c'est trop présente pas forcément non
plus la population
mais c'est surtout que pour pouvoir
juger il faut être informé
or vous voyez beaucoup de personnes qui
défilent à la télévision pour vanter
tous les mérites de la vidéosurveillance
est très rarement sont invités des gens
qui au contraire des ce qu' il faut
limiter ces dieux surveillance parce que
c'est une surveillance généralisée
donc il ya à boire et à manger là dedans
mais je pense que dresser en plus c'est
alors vous parlez du désengagement de
l'état
s'il n'y avait pas de délinquants de
l'état les mairies ne le ferai pas
admettons je veux bien je ne contredirai
pas sauf que ces caméras elles sont
justement rendu pratiquement obligatoire
par l'état donc si ce n'était pas vous
les maires qui le faisait ce serait
l'état qu'il ferait et moi je ne vous en
veux pas parce que vous êtes maire c'est
le sait le problème de siège en général
c'est que je mets en cause
j'ai compris c'est que celle que vous
fait dire cela
on entend beaucoup de critiques en ce
moment à juste titre d'ailleurs sur le
système chinois qui fait de la
reconnaissance faciale j'allais venir
gesterra mais on est en train de mettre
en place la même chose
la même chose sauf qu'aujourd'hui on
prend des précautions donc on y voit là
ça va être encadrés de telle façon
mais hélas je suis prêt à prendre rendez
vous dans vingt ans et vous verrez que
les loups ont évolué et que la
surveillance générale a reconnu social
qu il ya de fortes chances pour que ça
ait lieu
eh bien il vaut il faudrait aussi que
vous les maires vous m'initier quand
même de cette de cet argument je vous
rappelle que au fronton de toutes les
mairies
j'espère servir chez vous il ya un devis
cette liberté égalité fraternité et je
pense que de ce côté là vous aussi vous
devez vous
c'est la ligne en dessous des critiques
quelques secondes dans ce débat et vous
dire la chose suivante on peut toujours
faire peur et dire que le nôtre notre
modèle va vers le modèle chinois
d'abord le modèle chinois ce n'est pas
le modèle français et ne parlons pas de
reconnaissance physique ou en
connaissance facile alors la mairie de
monza c'est très bien c'est parfait mais
ce n'est pas nous nous sommes encadrés
par plusieurs collectivités pour mon
collègue cc saint quentin en yvelines
pour pour moi même c'est versailles
grand parc au dessus le département
conseil départemental et au dessus il ya
le conseil régional
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut voilà à
chaque fois qu'il ya une évolution qu'à
une innovation il ya bien sûr toutes les
forces qui sont pour et puis toutes les
autres forces qui freine c'est toujours
comme ça c'était la même chose pour la
voiture électrique
c'était la même chose pour la voiture
autonome en suisse a été la même chose
pour les portables
c'était la même chose pour internet au
début on a effrayé nos enfants dix ans
et d'ailleurs on fait même beaucoup de
pédagogie pour justement faire attention
avec avec nos enfants mais chaque
évolution chaque évolutions normatives
chaque innovation fait pas voilà ça
donne lieu à un débat entre les le
prenez pas mal pour les modernes et les
anciens je dis pas je suis moderne je
dis simplement c'est que c'est
l'expression qui consacre et c'est pour
ça que je dis ça il y a ceux qui restent
bien évidemment sur des schémas compassé
et d'autres qui essaye de voir si on
peut mieux lutter contre la délinquance
on a pris des exemples dramatiques
il ya un instant je dis pas moi je suis
pas je suis en charge de la vidéo
protection dans cette dans cette
agglomération j'en suis pas heureux
parce que j'installe 400 caméras sur 19
villes je consacre un budget de 2 3
millions d'euros par an non mais ce que
je veux dire par là c'est bien sûr ce
n'est pas un bonheur de mettre des
caméras revient dessus ce n'est pas un
bonheur et le bien est un bon jour et
comment
je sais que vous aimez beaucoup parlé
mais ce qui me permet lui six 6 mois
donc je voudrais quand même venir au
thème de l'émission c'était la vidéo
verbalisation protection et versailles
et protection et on a parlé de
protection mais pas beaucoup de
verbaliser
alors si vous allez venir jouer ou
rendre bien sûr voilà neuf derniers
matchs disposition encore encore une
fois vivement vivons avec nos temps mis
en mettant des garde-fous
mais justement là je conteste la façon
dont vous abordez le problème où il y
aurait une querelle entre les anciens et
les modernes
les entrées en plus non mais c'est
peut-être mais c'est ce qui est rentré
dans les cerveaux voyez-vous et je pense
que c'est parce à comprendre
moi je le place sur un autre plan ceux
qui défendent les libertés individuelles
et ceux qui les combattent
et donc jusqu'au bout et que les maires
combat des libertés moi je suis la mère
des libertés c'est notre sécurité mais
la mère de nos libertés c'est aussi
grâce à venir excusez moi le sma
terminer ma phrase il n'y a pas accès
sans liberté il n'y a pas de liberté
sans sécurité je n'y crois pas je pense
que le couple liberté et sécurité sont
la kxf honda mentale de la république
depuis tout temps depuis dix ans on dit
depuis la commune depuis toutes les
soulèvements ce que moi là intellectuels
de gauche comme de droite ont toujours
pensé que dans cette république
le couple sécurité et liberté de l'allée
ensemble alors les messieurs bientôt à
sa fin on va juste aborder la
vidéo-verbalisation puisque à montigny
vous utilisez la vidéo-verbalisation
donc comme j'ai dit au début de cette
émission l'utilisent sur deux places la
place la place claudel et puis au centre
commercial de la marque et lyon et au
départ quand on l'a installé à la place
claudel c'était à la demande des
commerçants qui sont autour de cette
place parce qu'on avait du stationnement
ventouses un stationnement ventouses et
donc
au bout d'un certain temps on va déjà
essayer une partie en zone bleue le
parti bon et puis on en est arrivé à la
conclusion c'est pas énorme il doit
avoir 38
on va dire 40 places autour de la
stationner donc on a la moitié de la
place qui est en vidéo verbalisation
face aux commerçants pour permettre
justement cette rotation et finalement
au bout d'un certain temps c'est rentré
dans les moeurs et les voitures tournent
et puis on à l'autre partie en zone
bleue et ça se passe très très bien
sur le place de montigny c'est beaucoup
plus limité donc j'en passe j'en
parlerai pas mais c'est pas non plus
j'irai quand je vois ce qui se passe à
londres par exemple ou tout le centre de
londres maintenant et vidéos verbaliser
quand tu as un véhicule rentre qu'il
n'est pas autorisé
on en est loin à bois d'arcy ça devrait
être testé d'ici l'été
c'est bien ça testez le terme est un peu
un peu excessif parce qu'on est en étude
pour l'instant on n'a pas fini les
études parce qu'il est un petit souci
majeur quand même je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure rapidement c'est que pour vidéo
verbalisé il faut des policiers
municipaux dans l'essai sur orne où
notre saison nous avons reversé fontenay
saint cyr l'école il n'y a pas de
policiers municipaux derrière les écrans
mais des des agents les agents
municipaux on en train de tester cela on
en train de 2,2 de préciser les critères
on leur phase d'étude et j'espère leur
navidi l'été mais je pense qu'on va
prendre un petit peu plus un petit
retard je pense qu'on fera dans les mois
qui viennent on fera un test sur un quoi
un quartier de balard si c'est le
carrefour de la mairie de bois d'arcy
on va essayer mais comme on est en
travaux ce moment sur le carrefour et
sur la fameuse avenue jean jaurès de
brenner si on pouvait le faire pour
l'instant donc c'est à reporter
plusieurs mois tiens des gens juste un
mot sur la vidéo verbalisation
je crois que ça rentre dans le cadre
général mais en plus donc de tout ce que
j'ai pu dire sur la surveillance
généralisée et alors c est aussi le
problème dont parle et la dame tout à
l'heure qu'ils étaient interviewés c'est
la déshumanisation dire qu'on va avoir
des appareils qui discutent entre eux
des ordinateurs qui discutent entre eux
et les citoyens eux
bah ils n'auront qu'un cas s'aligner
parce qu'il n'y a aucun moyen de dire le
contraire de contester ce groupe ça donc
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que de ce
côté là même on perd le sens la maison
pour le sandre concrètement félibrée
qu'on perd le sens même de la sanction
java sanctions en elle-même elle ces
propos la laisse pas forcément très
éducatif mais la petite part d'éducation
qu'elle peut avoir
elle est due au sens à partir du moment
où vous enlever tout ce côté humain vous
perdez le centre de la sanction est donc
bah vous dormez les logos des éducateurs
regarder dans les rues regardez dans les
rues le nombre de personnes qui marchent
en regardant leur smartphone ou prenez
le train en gare des jeunes ou les
personnes qui jouent mais oui c'est
moins humain et là je suis d'accord avec
vous mais vous vous voulez aller contre
ça et proposez quoi d'autre on fait quoi
mais ça touche bientôt à sa fin juste 10
secondes 10 20 secondes chacun pour pour
conclure du coup vidéoprotection vidéo
verbalisation
tu imagines pour vous c'est efficace il
ya une évolution naturelle il ya une
évolution de la lutte contre la
délinquance et des incivilités dans
notre pays aujourd'hui du fait de toutes
les causes qu'on a évoqué il ya un
instant il ya une évolution
une évolution qui est extrêmement bien
encadrés dans notre pays et j'ai
confiance dans la cadre e m'en fais sur
cette question là c'est une évolution
qui tend plutôt vers une fugue ni une
efficacité contre leur contre la
délinquance oui normal je veux blé dit
on à 75 caméras aujourd'hui donc on
continue modestement tranquillement
parce que les budgets sont ce qu'ils
sont à 1 implantée pour avoir un
maillage et surtout une efficacité
d'intervention de notre police
municipale qui grâce au csu permet à tel
ou tel patrouille d'aller plus
rapidement sur un endroit quand il ya un
problème et c'est ça l'efficacité c'est
ça principalement ce que les gens
demandent
oui moi je crois que j'ai effectivement
on ne prend pas encore en compte
suffisamment ce côté atteintes aux
libertés publiques et on propose en plus
des solutions qui ne répondent pas à
l'objectif fixé
oui c'est la fin de cette émission chose
suis désolé on se retrouve mercredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro 17 feed
débat
[Musique]